la fin de l'équipe et semblant de deux
ans terre en allemagne la police a tiré
au total leur pilotage aura fait trois
morts et sept blessés
la hausse des prix en france en juillet
+0 3% ce n'est pas présent e minute de
l'économie montre du doigt les loyers ce
sont eux les responsables de la hausse
nouvelle calédonie tout le monde se
retrouve autour de la table de
négociation de soir le référendum aurait
lieu au mois de novembre au liban
élection présidentielle reportée il n'y
avait pas assez de députés présents déjà
de nouveaux troubles à beyrouth
bonsoir avant de développer tous ces
titres un saut à la nouvelle orléans
c'est là bas que se tient vous le savez
la convention républicaine
les délégués ont officiellement choisi
george bush pour briguer la succession
de ronald reagan à la présidence bush
quoi elle s'est donc le ticket
républicain qui affrontera les
démocrates dukakis et bensen pour bien
comprendre l'enjeu de cette convention
nous allons y consacrer une page
spéciale dans ce journal avec notre
envoyé spécial jacquat bouchard au
crible la campagne de george bush le
rôle de ronald regan le choix du sud des
états unis
tout cela dans la deuxième partie de ce
journal met tout de suite à la nouvelle
orléans aux bords du mississipi nous
retrouvons jacquat bouchard jacques
bonsoir et bienvenue à la nouvelle
orléans par excellence la ville où les
français se sentent un peu chez eux aux
états unis la caméra vous a permis de
découvrir le majestueux mississippi qui
a inspiré tant d'écrivains de chanteur
de blues et de musiciens de jazz
ici on aime par dessus tout la fête
la vie nocturne et le carnaval de la
ville et célèbre à travers tout le pays
or il se déroule un drôle de carnaval
ici depuis trois jours je veux parler
bien sûr de la convention républicaine
mais nous aurons l'occasion d'y revenir
tout à l'heure dans la deuxième partie
de ce journal je vous présenterai
également quelques personnages
louisianais qui n'ont rien à voir avec
tout le tapage médiatique de la nouvelle
orléans
à tout à l'heure dans a tout de suite en
effet jacques est tout d'abord cette
prise d'otages sanglante en allemagne
elle s'est terminée tout à l'heure sur
une autoroute entre cologne et francfort
les policiers sont intervenus et tout
s'est terminée dans un bain de sang tout
avait commencé mardi matin par le
braquage d'une banque dans la roue
entre temps les gangsters avaient pris
un autocar en otage
récit isabelle bechler fin de l'équipe
est folle des deux braqueurs vers 14h
aujourd'hui sur une autoroute près de
bonn l'assaut de la police et sanglant
une otage et tuer l'autre est très
grièvement blessé et deux gangsters une
complice et deux femmes d'otages étaient
à bord d'une voiture poursuivie par la
police depuis la frontière hollandaise
un policier s'est déjà tué dans la
course poursuite les régions de police
se sont mis en travers de la route et ça
a tiré dans tous les sens vous avez eu
peur c'est sûr tout le monde s'est jeté
par terre
tout commence donc mardi avant-hier dans
une banque de la ruhr à gladbeck de
gangsters originaire de la ville l'un
est en cavale depuis deux ans
réussissent à hold up but 1 1 million et
demi de francs les deux hommes
puissamment armés existe alors une
voiture que la police va leur fournir et
il s'enfuit en prenant déjà en otage
deux employés de la banque
ils vont se perdre dans la nature toute
une journée ils changent de voiture à
plusieurs reprises sur la route de brême
là il relâche les deux employés de la
banque tirent des coups de feu sur un
marché semble paniqués ils vont prendre
un bus municipal en otage à bord une
trentaine de passagers quelques uns
arrivent à s'échapper
la détermination des gangsters est
terrible il me lasse indifféremment
jeunes et vieux plus tard ils vont tuer
un de leurs otages quelques heures après
avoir accordé une interview à la
télévision allemande
seros honneur le chef qui parle
apparemment fatigué mais calme et un
sang froid étonnant
son complice menacent toujours les
otages du bus maison de correction et
toute la suite j'ai déjà passé 14 ans
tall et je n'ai plus rien à perdre
d'ailleurs je suis sûr de m'en sortir
mais si ça tournait mal
je m'en fous je me flatte
la tragique épopée continue 2 heures du
matin sur un parking des pays-bas
l'angoissent toujours pour 25 otages
secteur bouclé par la police
les gangsters réclame de l'argent encore
et une voiture la police va céder
libération des otages sauf deux femmes
qui l'emmène jeudi à l'aube les
braqueurs devenu meurtrier vont repartir
vers le sud vers le dénouement de leur
affaire trois morts et sept blessés un
bilan tragique bien sûr mais surtout des
images et donc une présence quasi
constante de la télévision qui ont
choqué le public allemand
la critique principale ce soir ans et
reste à vivre
l'incompétence et le laxisme de la
police allemande en france les policiers
lyonnais serait sur le point
d'identifier le trio à la 205 gti rouge
les policiers agissent dans la plus
grande discrétion
mais il semble progresser dans leur
enquête les trois hommes au cours de
leur équipée sanglante depuis samedi
dernier ont commis un meurtre un viol et
plusieurs agressions dans la région de
lyon et de grenoble et puis je la prends
à l'instant la mort du gendarme blessé
par les évadés de la prison d'auxerre
le maréchal des logis chef michel astoul
avait eu la carotide tranchée de
plusieurs coups de couteau portés par
thierry courtois et son complice
stéphane besle lorsqu'il s'était évadé
de la prison d'auxerre c'était le 9 août
dernier et stéphane besle avaient été
tués lors de son arrestation
le gendarme blessé et donc mort les
loyers augmentent trop vite en france et
le ministre de l'économie pierre
bérégovoy qui l'a dit en rendant public
lundi ce des prix c'est l indice insee
du mois de juillet ils indiquent une
augmentation de 0,3 pour cent ce n'est
pas un très bon avis mais il traduit
tout de même une augmentation un petit
peu trop forte par rapport à nos
partenaires commerciaux comme
l'allemagne principale cause de cet
indice médiocre ce sont donc les loyers
ils ont augmenté plus vite que la
moyenne des autres prix c'est ce
qu'affirme monsieur bérégovoy
explication claire chazal bête noire de
tous les ministres des finances soucieux
d' enrayer l'inflation les loyers
bloqués de 82 à 87 par la loi quillot
ils sont restés à peu près sage mais des
86 le dérapage s'amorce depuis cette
date le coût de location progresse deux
fois plus vite que l'indicé général des
prix
avec la libération des loyers prévu par
la loi méhaignerie de décembre 87
les hausses atteignent même souvent 20%
à paris un emballement dénoncé
aujourd'hui par la rue de rivoli pu
observer que les loyers avaient augmenté
depuis un an de plus de 6 5%
ils augmentent plus vite que l'inflation
alors il faut donc que les propriétaires
soient sérieux est-ce qu'on pourrait
revenir un blocage des loyers non mais
il faut que les dispositions de la loi
méhaignerie souhaite appliquer à
l'occasion du renouvellement des baux
cela dit selon l'insee le relèvement
trimestriel des loyers de juillet marque
plutôt une petite décélération
les propriétaires en tout cas se veulent
rassurants la rentabilité de
l'immobilier doit être préservé et il
faut peut-être tenir compte d'une
disparité qui peut exister entre le
marché parisien et le reste de
l'hexagone en ce qui concerne le marché
de province laissons jouer la loi du
marché pleinement et je crois que les
loyers auront tendance à se stabiliser
de même pour le moment pourtant la loi
méhaignerie semble poser de gros
problèmes d'application les litiges
entre locataires et propriétaires libre
de fixer le loyer au moment du
renouvellement du bail se termine en
effet trop souvent devant des tribunaux
de plus en plus engorgées la critique
des communistes georges marchais faisait
le point cet après-midi sur les
préparatifs de la fête de l'huma ce sera
le 10 et 11 septembre prochains selon
monsieur marché le bilan de michel
rocard depuis un mois et demi est
négatif et ce bilan s'inscrit dans la
continuité du gouvernement précédent
ce sont les termes du secrétaire général
du parti communiste la nouvelle
calédonie les discussions ont continué
toute la journée à paris au ministère
des dom tom
le ministre a reçu successivement les
délégations du rpcr puis du fln caisse
alors tout le monde ce soir se
retrouvent ensemble au ministère des dom
tom
rachid arhab vous êtes sur place au
ministère alors est-ce qu'on a progressé
un petit peu aujourd'hui dans les
négociations regardez ça semble avancer
pour l'instant il convient de rester
prudent vous l'avez dit louis le pensec
a reçu dans la journée
les deux délégations celle du fn qu'à
séduire pressèrent il les a reçus
séparément maintenant nous nous
préparons une
nuit de discussions il y à quelques
minutes les représentants du rpcr avec
10 q où en tête sont arrivés vous allez
voir sur ces images disques et aux
équipes et n'est donc la délégation du
rpcr qui sont arrivés au ministère des
dom tom pour cette séance plénière nous
attendons encore pour l'instant
l'arrivée de jean marie tjibaou et de la
délégation du fndd caisse
ce qu'on peut dire également c'est que
même si rien ne filtre des conversations
nous savons que chacun des deux chefs de
délégations dit kiko et et jean marie
tjibaou a donc proposé des amendements
au projet de loi qui leur a été
présentée hier par louis le pensec alors
de quoi s'agit-il précisément hervé pour
prendre un exemple de celui qu'on
appelle les mesures d'accompagnement
économique et social le ministre des
dom-tom après avoir entendu les deux
délégations a fait le tour cet après
midi de ses collègues du gouvernement un
tour téléphonique pour essayer de savoir
quel crédit
il était possible de débloquer ce soir
lui le passage de toutes les délégations
seront arrivées fera donc le point avec
monsieur tjibaou et monsieur luc et cela
concerne les mesures concrètes pratiques
pour ce qui est par exemple des mesures
telles que la mystique et vous le savez
est réclamée fortement par le fln ks les
discussions vont certainement continuer
ce soir avec apparemment une avancée
possible a aussi revu hier rachid
monsieur le pensec dans ce journal
d'ailleurs disait qu'il espérait aboutir
avant la fin de la semaine vous pensez
que c'est toujours possible alors en
tout cas il ya un certain optimisme de
mise ici
au ministère des dom tom ont c'est donc
qu'on va discuter toute la nuit cela dit
on se prépare à discuter encore demain
et peut-être demain soir donc on pense
encore pouvoir en terminer d'ici samedi
on pense encore que les deux délégations
pourrait repartir en nouvelle calédonie
dimanche
merci rachid les élections américaines
tout de suite voyage express à la
nouvelle orléans la nuit dernière le
vice président américain george bush a
été désigné candidat du parti
républicain c'est lui donc qui
représentera ce parti à l'élection
présidentielle de novembre
george bush qui a 64 ans souffre
toujours d'une réputation d'éternel
second il joue maintenant sa chance mais
son portrait reste toujours un peu flou
nous retrouvons jacquat bouchard à la
nouvelle orléans ou et georges
c'est le cri de guerre des adversaires
démocrates de bouche mais écoutez plutôt
ce qu'ils disent
pendant les 80 sa vice présidence george
bush à passer davantage de temps sur les
courts de tennis que dans son bureau de
travail
vrai faux mais qui est vraiment george
bush ramassé une veste autrement dit
subir une défaite n'est pas dans le
style de george bush
sa brillante carrière en témoigne et
tout au long de la campagne sous divers
accoutrements il s'est efforcé de
convaincre ses compatriotes qu'il était
un athlète complet digne d'occuper le
bureau ovale présidentielle il a
également tenté de gommer une image qui
le dessert dans le public
celle d'un fils à papa peu sensible au
souci des plus défavorisés george bush
c'est le monsieur 20 sur 20 de la
politique américaine avec une belle
carte de visite et des états de service
en forme d'image d'epinal
pilote de l'us air force il a effectué
50 une mission pendant la guerre contre
le japon
il fut aussi bon joueur de baseball à
l'université de yale que brillant
étudiant
après un court crochet par l'industrie
pétrolière au texas
il est entré en politique soutenue par
sa jeune épouse barbara résultats
mitigés un succès au congrès un échec au
sénat de washington
il enchaîne pourtant les postant du
ambassadeur aux nations unies à new york
président du parti républicain c'est le
retour à la politique active
représentants des états unis à pékin une
nouvelle et brève aventure diplomatique
puis directeur de la cia l'agencé
centrale américaine de renseignement
en 1980 le candidat reggane choisi comme
colistier george bush concurrent le plus
sérieux qu'il se cantonnera pendant huit
ans dans un rôle effacé
malgré ses nombreux contacts au plus
haut niveau l'homme des républicains
sont 1988 cherche à rassurer dans son
rôle de chef de famille car l'amérique
conservatrice le suspecte du crime de
libéralisme
or c'est elle qui a fait la fortune de
reggane c'est elle qui scellera le
destin présidentiel
ce george bush l'amérique conservatrice
on aurait bien repris pour quatre ans à
la maison blanche avec ronald reagan au
summum de sa popularité
ronald a quitté en fanfare le devant de
la scène pour laisser la place à georges
mais at-il vraiment contribué à placer
son second sur la bonne trajectoire pour
gagner vice président george bush
ronald reagan si elle est engagée
publiquement
je travaillerai de toutes les forces
pour que george bush soit le prochain
président des états unis dans un premier
temps son appui à chambley bien timide
le scandale des ventes d'armes à l'iran
n'a rien arrangé avec le renvoi du
colonel north et de l'amiral paul dexter
de conseiller de la maison blanche
et puis il ya eu les accusations de
corruption lancées contre edwin mise le
ministre de la justice et les magouilles
de l'administration régale avec le
général panaméen noriega considéré comme
un gros bonnet de la drogue
on en venait à se demander si le
président souhaitait vraiment la
victoire de son second il a fini par
sortir de sa réserve
à la veille de son voyage à moscou
malgré des résultats modestes
le sommet a été considérée comme un
succès dont george bush a su exploiter
les retombées en acceptant la démission
de son ami edwin mise
ronald reagan a donné un nouveau coup de
pouce au vice président candidat
même démarche avec l'octroi en urgence
de 4 milliards de dollars d'indemnités
aux fermiers victimes de la sécheresse
de plus le président fait plusieurs
apparitions publiques aux côtés de son
second il a attaqué durement dukakis
allant jusqu'à le traiter d'un valide
avant de devoir présenter des excuses
enfin devant une convention républicaine
chauffé à blanc ronald reagan a présenté
george bush comme le rempart de la
démocratie américaine
face à ces adversaires présentés comme
de dangereux trublion la pauvreté le
chômage sont deux thèmes clés de la
campagne électorale en louisiane les
deux principales industries la pêche et
le pétrole sont en crise et les
conséquences sont durement ressentie
dans les bayous les canaux de
l'embouchure du mississippi
c'est jour de fête sur le bayou la foule
on a décoré les bateaux et monseigneur
l'évêque est venu donner sa bénédiction
pour l'ouverture de la nouvelle campagne
de pêche dans ce coin de louisiane à
deux heures de la nouvelle orléans ont
shalit la crevette contrôle selon
l'expression locale parce qu'il est
indien joe billio s'est abstenu de
participer à la cérémonie religieuse
dans la camionnette
il a chargé enfants et petits enfants
qui veulent le voir embarquer jo billio
est l'un des cent mille pêcheurs
louisianais qui sillonnent les bayous
les canaux à l'embouchure du mississippi
il ne reverra les chiens qu'en de rares
occasions pendant les sept mois de la
saison de pêche jo bhi liot fait figure
de privilégiés car peu d'indiens sont
propriétaires de leur chalutier pourtant
ils peinent à remplir les cales du
capitaine aide à cause de la concurrence
acharnée et de la surexploitation des
bandes crevettes
en fait il vit au smig américains
environ 5000 francs par mois et il se
range dans la catégorie des pauvres bien
port et à bord ils font un travail
aujourd'hui pour le mauvais de manoeuvre
ça c'est comme ça on a été élevé c'est
comme ça mon père et mon grand père et
mon grand père l'a fait et c'est comme
ça
m
béatrice mais quand même vous voulez pas
abandonner le métier de pêcheur
c'est la seule chose qu'on connaît on a
pas d'école à l'apa est instruit en ont
fait un sac non tenues par et notre
grand père nous a montré et c'est tous
le monde peut montrer à mes enfants je
peux pas les voir les moteurs quoi
franchement connais pas je peux montrer
ce type que je connais dans le métier
mais non
trois des fils de joe billio se sont
résignés à devenir pêcheur faute d'étude
suffisamment poussées à la grande
déception de leur père à 68 ans loulon
pitre un authentique cage un ami sac à
terre après 40 ans de pêche
il soigne ses parcs à huîtres mais toi
tout ça était tout près nous est passé
le ragondin venu sûr que les vrais
passionnés de politique le long pitre ne
veut pas entendre parler de bush à la
maison blanche
ils sont pas un président ils sont pas
un président à ce qui touche à ma
président bush son président
le long ne débordent pas non plus de
sympathie pour le démocrate dukakis
l'autre bourgoin comme il dit mais en
concluant avec philosophie
on est en amérique et il faut bien
manger ce qu'il ya dans l'assiette
douze mille et peut-être quinze mille
journalistes
plusieurs centaines de stations de
télévision c'est vraiment la ruée
sauvage de la presse sur la louisiane
pour couvrir l'événement nous nous
sommes allés à la rencontre d'une
journaliste local elle vit elle
travaille à 100 km de la nouvelle
orléans
en réalité elle est à des années
lumières de la convention républicaine
elle avait débarqué en louisiane il y à
12 ans pour quelques jours de vacances
avec deux valises
aujourd'hui de nice au teint est une
célébrité locale
bonjour je suis béni dans save au levier
en france le 17e jour du mois d'aôut on
reconnaît que la convention elle est
publique et nationale formant ce succès
on se revoit l'année prochaine denise
doute un anime quotidiennement un
programme de 30 minutes en français
cajun le seul de son genre suivie par 40
mille spectateurs avant de gagner
durement ses galons de vedette
elle a été femme de chambre et laver la
vaisselle dans un restaurant reporter
missions parfois périlleuses denise
d'autun est aussi litoria l'isq
présentatrice des nouvelles et rien de
ce qui touche à la politique ne la
laisse indifférente
comment votre temps dans cette région de
louisiane parmi les quinze jeunes
francophones
les quinze jeunes francophones sont
démocrates des démocrates alors est un
pas georges bush non parce que c'est
affiliés à harry caine et on a avoué
très bien sur quatre ans passés mais pas
ici dans la paroisse de la force et ses
démocrates et autant que les
et reagan et bush avant tout le monde et
celle ci se poser c'est des mots
en toute modestie déclare denise je me
montre peu en public car la célébrité
voyez-vous est parfois dur à porter
merci jacques abou chaar merci excusez
moi de voir couper la parole merci pour
cette page spéciale américaine dans
l'actualité de ce jeudi encore le
pakistan après la mort du président aux
ja l'état d'urgence a été déclaré dans
ce pays
les autorités craignent des troubles
après l'accident d'avion qui a coûté la
vie donc au président dia l'explosion de
l'avion serait bien du un sabotage c'est
ce qu'a affirmé le ministère de la
défense pakistanais l'avion s'est écrasé
dix minutes après son décollage à bord
il y avait 29 personnes dont
l'ambassadeur américain au liban
l'élection présidentielle a été reportée
ce sont les députés qui élisent là-bas
le président il n'y avait que 38 députés
présents le quorum n'a donc pas été
atteint
il semble aussi que la candidature du
pro syriens frangié et provoquer une
réaction des autres formations
chrétiennes jacques merlino ce qui était
prévu s'est produit le parlement
libanais ce matin a pu siéger le très
important dispositif de sécurité mis en
place n'a rien changé
un député sur deux a préféré rester chez
lui de gré ou de force plutôt que
d'aller voter selon la constitution
libanaise pour être élu président de la
république il faut recueillir les deux
tiers des votes au parlement soit un
minimum de 53 voix or ce matin il n'y
avait que 38 députés
la raison de cet échec est simple le
candidat le plus sérieux monsieur
sleimane frangié est aux yeux de tous ce
candidat des syriens il a contre lui à
important des chrétiens de beyrouth et
surtout l'opposition farouche des forces
libanaises les principales milices
chrétiennes son côté que les deux vrais
électeurs sont en réalité damas et
washington et que les américains
verraient d'un très mauvais oeil un pro
syriens devenir président du liban la
situation est donc bloquée et tout
laisse croire qu'il n'ya pas de solution
à court terme la date limite pour cette
élection est temps fixé au 23 septembre
en afrique du sud nelson mandela est
malade le leader noir emprisonnés
auraient la tuberculose le président
botha a fait preuve de cynisme
aujourd'hui il a renouvelé son offre de
libérer mandela à condition que celui-ci
coopèrent en condamnant le recours à la
violence mandela bien sûr s'y est
toujours refusée philippe lefait
commentaire la légende ne même plus ce
visage
nelson mendela l'a perdu en 1962 quand
il est devenu le matricule 466 64 et le
prisonnier est devenu très vieux
soixante dix ans son image ses écrits et
ses paroles sont interdits au public sud
africain depuis sa condamnation pour
complot le mythe mendela aurait la
tuberculose l'homme en tout cas été
opérée ici le week-end dernier
quelle que soit la gravité de
l'affection pulmonaire qui le ronge son
hospitalisation inquiète son entourage
et rend malade le pouvoir blanc de
pretoria ne voit-on pas le président
botha devant son parti souhaitait un
prompt rétablissement à celui qui fait
figure de terroristes il n'y a même pas
de cynisme dans cette amabilité à
l'endroit d'un hors la loi il est vrai
que la mort en prison du plus célèbre
prisonnier d'afrique en ferait un martyr
de la cause noire et de l'apartheid
la presse sud-africaine les modérés du
pouvoir ne s'y trompe pas qui réclame
une libération rapide
pieter botha il met une nouvelle fois
comme exigence un renoncement à la
violence
l'indomptable mendela a toujours dit non
pour ces millions de noirs qui ont fait
de lui un héros sans visage et qui sont
eux malades de l'apartheid toujours une
grande tension en birmanie les
dirigeants du pays se prépare à choisir
un nouveau chef de l'état des centaines
de milliers de personnes ont manifesté
dans les grandes villes birman et puis
des massacres au coeur de l'afrique au
burundi précisément des affrontements
entre des ethnies rivales aurait fait de
très nombreuses victimes dans ce pays
qui s'étaient déjà déchiré il ya une
vingtaine d'années à l'époque les
massacres avaient fait plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de morts le reste
de l'actualité tout de suite
nicolas jacobs
anomalie des rails avaient noté les
responsables de la guerre de blogolo voy
mais il oublie de prévenir le conducteur
du moscou leningrad bilan 24 morts 106
blessés dont 23 enfants
le conducteur n'a pas vu les panneaux de
limitation de vitesse à 60
kilomètres/heure poser la veille à 150
km heure le train a déraillé
puis à petits feux barrages de bus à
stettin 1000 employés en grève bateaux à
quai 2000 dockers les bras croisés tout
comme les mineurs de haute silésie
ils réclament des salaires indexés sur
les prix et surtout la reconnaissance du
syndicat solidarité lech walesa déclare
aujourd'hui la grève est désormais la
seule méthode efficace
alors que les manifestations se
poursuivent dans les territoires occupés
les autorités israéliennes décident
d'interdire les comités populaires
palestiniens véritables relais de la
direction clandestine du soulèvement
ces comités organisent en particulier
les manifestations et leur interdiction
risque d'être interprétée par les
palestiniens comme une provocation
apprendre à conduire dès l'âge de 16 ans
sera possible en septembre dans toute la
france d'abord 20 heures de formation en
auto école puis conduite accompagnée
d'un adulte jusqu'à l'examen du permis
toujours à 18 ans les jeunes formés par
cette technique aurait six à sept fois
moins d'accidents que les au football
est sélectionné pour france
tchécoslovaquie c'est un match amical
qui aura lieu mercredi prochain mais ce
sera tout de même un test avant les
qualifications de la coupe du monde 90
les qualifications qui commence dès
septembre alors pour ce france
tchécoslovaquie donc pas de grand
changement pour les gardiens et les
défenseurs en revanche nouveauté pour le
milieu de terrain avec deux premières
sélections
franck sauzée et jacky paillard
marseille et toulouse respectivement qui
en attaque retour de daniel veret des
retours aussi de stéphane paille les
vacances au bord de la mer beaucoup
d'enfants sont privés il faut savoir que
près d'une famille sur deux ne part pas
l'été d'où une grande opération du
secours populaire qui a emmené dix mille
enfants à malo les bains près de
dunkerque 8 trains spéciaux avaient été
mobilisés pour cette opération
reportage pascal deschamps jean-françois
bernigaud
une gare un train qui démarre et c'est
déjà un peu les vacances
six ans que nelly ses soeurs n'avaient
pas fait un si grand voyage 300 km pour
aller voir la mer c'est un événement
quand on ne parle presque jamais fait
entendre qu'il n'est pas d'aller là à la
mer
qu'est ce que tu as emporté avec toi ma
soeur
autant maillot sur moi
savoir que l'on soit rohff rendre
oui
nelly sa famille ont quitté leur petite
maison de la banlieue parisienne que
deux fois en neuf ans et encore pour
passer l'été chez les coudes cette année
encore pour le père chauffeur routier en
préretraite et la mer modeste employé
les comptes ont été vite fait grâce à
l'année prochaine
d'accord
cette année c'était pas possible on
n'aime pas demander à droite à gauche
alors les organisateurs ont finalement
réussi à convaincre les parents de dix
mille enfants dont 7000 pour la seule
région parisienne tous oubliés des
vacances enfants de chômeurs ou de
familles frappées par la pauvreté
dix mille enfants du jamais vu sur la
plage de malo-les-bains
certains découvraient la mer la vie éco
rues et pillé et j'ai fait c'est pas
trop difficile de nager dans la mer
pour cette journée de la solidarité
cette journée pas comme les autres il
aura tout de même fallu trouver près de
200 francs par enfant
il y avait un tiercé quarté aujourd'hui
c'était c'était à enghien alors voici
les résultats 11 13 8 pour le tiercé 11
13 8 et 10 pour le quarté vous pouvez
lire comme moi les résultats sur votre
écran
le dernier journal ce sera donc la
dernière édition le dernier rendez vous
de l'information pour ce soir ce sera
tard un petit peu après minuit philippe
le fait tout de suite vous avez rendez
vous avec mon camarade laurent cabrol
pour une météo vous allez voir laurent
est un peu morose
bonne soirée sur antenne 2 à demain soir
ah ah